[Music]
[Applause]
chris mannix kind enough to uh join us
early on the west coast after uh last
night's performance here have you been
to sleep chris
uh briefly um i just uh removed the papa
john's pizza box from my bed so um i'm
feeling okay right now a little uh a
little tired but i'm okay how
sustainable is this for the boston
celtics
very sustainable um i picked the celtics
to win this series in six and my biggest
concern coming in
was not if there would be a talent gap
between the teams but how overwhelmed
the celtics would be by the moment um
golden state 123 games of finals
experience the celtics zero
that matters you go back to 2012 and
look at the oklahoma city thunder team
that played miami in the finals you
could make the argument that even with
lebron wade and bosh that thunder team
was at least as talented or more
talented they just were overwhelmed in
part by the moment um beyond like the
first couple of minutes of game one
the celtics weren't overwhelmed by the
moment they were very much present and
they survived you know a finals record
first quarter from steph curry to only
be down by four they had a lead at
halftime they had what has become
their traditional third quarter pooping
of the bed and then came back and
rallied and you know outscored uh you
know the golden state 40 to 13 before
steve kerr threw in the towel in the
fourth quarter they're just i just think
they're the better team dan in this
series and if they're not going to get
shook by playing in the finals um
they're gonna show it
yeah i think and i agree with you after
the first quarter and step puts up 21
and then you realize all right we we
withstood a knockout blow
and then you're leading at halftime and
i went this bodes well for boston
then they fell behind and then it's like
golden state's up by 11 and i go
all right maybe golden state learned its
lesson and uh they'll close this out and
then all of a sudden here they come but
al horford can you
see that i guess there's a couple ways
to look at this you go if you're a
boston fan we won on the road and jayson
tatum didn't play well
we could steal another one here or does
golden state go we just didn't shoot
that well and they're not going to shoot
that well and it was really one bad
quarter here
i i think look you can look at it both
ways um i'm sure golden state's taking
the latter attitude and boston certainly
is is taking the former i mean i i don't
think you can expect you know derek
white to shoot that well in game two al
horford to go four for four in the
fourth quarter with a couple of threes i
mean everything was working for the
celtics shooting-wise in the fourth
quarter i mean the shots that marcus
smart
wasn't making in game seven against
miami he was making uh in game one
against golden state all that being said
tatem offensively was abysmal like this
was just a bad fourth quarter he was bad
all game three for 17 was awful for
jason tatum to his credit he had 13
assists and so he stuck with and didn't
force uh as many shots but if you're the
celtics
your head of the snake plays that bad
offensively you can't have a lot of
confidence going into game two because
you know
like
as much as golden state can be
optimistic about what they can do the
celtics aren't going to get rushed like
that by steph curry again in the first
quarter they're not going to allow my
golden state to shoot 48
in the first quarter their defense held
the warriors to 42 in the second half
that's more likely going to happen in
game two the celtics defense is that
good so
i think if you're boston you know you're
going to take the biggest punch golden
state's got but
you've got to believe you can come away
with two games in the series see i
didn't buy into the they don't have any
experience but then i saw jason tatum
look like he didn't have any experience
yeah you got a rookie head coach
two other rookie head coaches have
beaten golden state in the nba finals
um
you know like so the players have to
have experience but a coach doesn't have
to have experience i think udoka did a
wonderful job uh certainly in the second
quarter or second half in the fourth
quarter whereas steve kerr uh it felt
like he got out coached
yeah look
the facts are email udoka has
bested mike budenholzer and eric
spoelstra already in these playoffs and
those have been seven game series where
coaching matters he has pushed the right
buttons
in two series already so it's no
surprise to see him
come up with the game plan that helps
the celtics win game one but to me
imei udoka's
best uh performance wasn't necessarily
in this game it's what he's done with
this team all season i mean dan i'm in
boston i'm at most of these celtics
games i can't underscore how abysmal it
was the first two months of the season
when they were just awful blowing leads
and
sniping at each other and looking like
they might be lottery bound at the end
of december imei udoka
instilled in this team a mental
toughness that they didn't have in years
past so when they go down 3-2 against
milwaukee in the second round they don't
panic when they lose games six badly at
home to miami they don't panic and just
like in previous games where they've
blown third quarter uh leads or had
awful third quarters they don't panic
jason tatum said it best after the game
he's like at the start of the fourth
quarter emery said to us we've been here
before and they have so
i think his coaching was excellent in
game one but this was just a
continuation of what i thought was one
of the best coaching performances of
this entire season yeah i thought he did
a wonderful job and it showed last night
doesn't seem like the moment's too big
for him
uh
what's the poll question we have today
paulie that we're going to go with which
would who would uh an mvp of the finals
do more for steph curry or al horford
i mean
the narrative around steph curry is that
he needs it right that it would elevate
him into a different stratosphere
whether it's he goes from top 15 to top
10 whatever you want to say um
[Music]
i
probably step because i think just a
championship is good for al horford like
i mean al
who has been the bridesmaid how many
times now four times you know going to
conference finals atlanta boston now he
finally gets here i mean as i'm watching
that game last night dan it's like you
just can't forget that this guy was
acquired for kemba walker like he was he
was available to everybody in the league
and the celtics got him effectively for
a guy oklahoma city just bought out and
a mid first round pick i mean that that
to me is is remarkable and derek white
you know could have been had by many
teams in the league acquired for
effectively
a mid first round pick i mean the
buttons that brad stevens has pushed
this year with this team have been
remarkable where would this team be
without al horford and derek white two
guys that were not on the team at the
end of the last year we're talking to
chris mannix sports illustrated nba
senior writer what do you think the
first order of business for darvin ham
is with the lakers
ask rob polenka how the russell
westbrook talks are going i mean
i mean doesn't it really just come down
to that
you know darvingham is either preparing
for
mission impossible in bas in a
basketball sense which is trying to find
a way
to make it work with russell westbrook
or going into the season with a more
balanced roster i mean frankly dartmouth
ham doesn't really know
what team he's going to be coaching come
early october he knows lebron will be
there he knows adv will be there but
this was a team dan that had
how many minimum contract guys last year
they'll have a whole swath of new
players uh coming in this year and we
don't know what's gonna happen with
westbrook so i think it's who's going to
be on this roster and what kind of
players fit how i'm going to play now if
darvin ham is being told unequivocally
that russell westbrook will be part of
this team
to me his first order of business is
sitting down with russell westbrook and
saying russ
you can extend your career by five years
if you become a sixth man look at some
of the guys that have done it the jamal
crawford's the the players of that ilk
that have been long time starters
transitioned to six men and had
productive careers russell westbrook dan
if he doesn't become a sixth man or
become more of a role player his career
ends after this season simple as that
nobody's going to assign him to be a
starter in this league but if he's
willing to make that transition he's
willing to make that turn he could have
a five six year career because he could
still play well against second unit
types of guys so if i'm darpan ham who
as you've heard already from many people
connects well with players well-liked
guy throughout this league i'm sitting
down russell westbrook and i'm telling
him that's the best way to extend my
career good stuff chris thanks for
getting up and uh we'll talk to you soon
you got it dan that's chris mannix
sports illustrated nba senior writer
joining us from san francisco